well thank you very much ready for that
kind introduction um and I want to also
thank all of you people turning out on a
Saturday morning here to listen to me
talk about my book this is John Brown
the legend revisited now just in case to
refresh your memory that's put it over
John Brown was a radical abolitionist
who of course met his death on the
gallows at Charlestown Virginia December
2nd 1859 after conviction in a Virginia
Court on three counts the charge treason
murder and incitement of slaves now the
book is not a biography in a strict
sense it is study rather of the John
Brown and American thought and
imagination as a hero as a martyr his
martyrdom really is what came to define
him and of course came to be of course
the well obviously the critical act of
his life I do think though though it is
not a biography that it's a throws
shafts of light on the historical figure
of John Brown that it in other words
plays in the biography you might say and
I would hope would have some influence
in that area I had not thought that I
would write a book about strong brown I
had of course as Ray has pointed out
written books a number of books in
American history but I not thought to
write about John Brown partly because
when I was in graduate school I know
studying American history Brown was
pretty much ignored his reputation had
reached a low point at least among
academic historians professional
historians and I I learned nothing about
John Brown when I was in college the
approach that I use in this book is
resemblance resembles my book books on
Jefferson
the Jefferson image in American mind and
on Lincoln Lincoln in American memory
it's similar
some of you know those books will
recognize certain similarities though
all these men of course are very much
individuals so that the and their
careers are very different so the book
has to be tailored to that particular
individual and that means it's it's
differently the one thing I can say
about this book is it is shorter than
what my previous books have been and
some will some of you I can see are
happy to hear that um so what happened
was that back a couple years ago or so I
made a casual reading of Russell banks
historical novel cloud splitter which is
a brown brown and his family and so on
and it gave me a view of him that I
hadn't had before and so I thought that
I would like to know more about him and
that's what has led to this book now I'd
like to describe and characterize the
book by running a quick run-through of
the of the chapters they're only what
other five or six six chapters I guess
for Ken Romero myself six chapters and
then a coda at the end and then I will
on occasion
read some passages from the book
give you a better feel about it the
chapter one I call the John Brown epic
and that focuses on the raid at Harpers
Ferry and it's repercussions throughout
the Union on both north and south and
its impact upon the coming of a war that
was already being pronounced by
Republicans at least as irrepressible
Harper's the after Harpers Ferry
well Fort Sumter occurred sixteen months
after that and so it obviously has
played into the coming of the Civil War
in a very significant sense the Henry
Moore writing here now in the first
chapter yes John Brown's hectic the
threads the threads of the narrative of
his life are woven into the narrative
and I think that there is a sort of a
sketch you might say of his life before
the crowning event at Harpers Ferry he
was born in Connecticut in 1800 and he
was the son of the Puritans and his
family in 1805 moved out to Hudson Ohio
he was five years old and Ohio was then
a brand-new state Hudson Ohio was a
brand new town it was in the western
reserve of Connecticut a strip of land
below the Lake Erie which was reserved
from the creation the public domain to
Connecticut or sullen and
there he there he grew up and Hudson was
a very important part of his life the
what the fact that he was there chorus
was very significant because the Western
Reserve became an opposition stronghold
and John Brown from the time he was a
time he was a very young man
participated actively in the Underground
Railroad which was of course in Ohio
from the Ohio River up to Lake Erie
there was a lot of traffic on the
Underground Railroad and Brown was
always a helpmate for fugitive slaves
seeking the star of freedom in Canada
and so it came to be known actually the
Western Reserve after his death or it
may be even before I'm not quite sure as
the John Brown track which emphasizes
the importance of that a where he grew
up to his fervent abolitionism which was
a sort of characteristic of that region
he came to believe that he had a divine
mission to free the slaves and he began
to think about how he might accomplish
this in the 1840s he made a plan that he
called the Appalachian pathway under
which you would entice slaves into the
Appalachians move them north and so out
of slavery and he talked about this plan
in Springfield Massachusetts with
Frederick Douglass the great freed slave
the leader of
the blacks in in this country during the
antebellum years of
now the rain to come back to Harpers
Ferry the raid at Harpers Ferry was a
flat failure all the way around it
didn't free any slaves and it took the
lives of all but five of the 22
participants in it it was dismissed with
contempt in the opinion of both north
and south at that time at but after
Browns trial in Virginia Court in
Charlestown and his defense there he
came to be well many people were
impressed with his conduct his
principles his courage he had been
wounded in his capture and so he was
being tried at the beginning anyway
lying on a pallet before the judge
if you Brown was one admiration and
praise as that's the point is that the
public opinion in the North changed and
in the South in the South Valley
originally dismissed arrayed with
somewhat contempt as I say they began to
believe that it might foreshadow what
was to come and so public opinion became
very angry about this and angry at the
north and northern opinion has expressed
an oppressed and pulpit and everywhere
which was generally turning favorably
towards John Brown
then of course the the fact that he was
met his death by hanging
meant that he became a martyr one of the
most interesting things about the man
was is that he made himself into a
martyr quite deliberately quite
consciously in his jail cell in
Charlestown so that's what he saw
finally and he realized that that would
be his best work a lot of other people
felt the same way
among them Henry Ward Beecher who was
probably the most celebrated Protestant
minister in the country at his church of
the Plymouth Church in Brooklyn
Beecher preached a sermon at Brooklyn's
Plymouth Church I'm reading now from my
book the Sunday before Browns sentencing
that caught up in a few words the power
he had come to embody and which he
appreciated as I've indicated let no man
pray that Braun be spared Beecher said
that Virginia make him a martyr now he
is only blundered his soul was noble his
work miserable but a court and a gibbet
would redeem all that and round up
Browns failure with a heroic success the
prisoner upon here reading these words
as he did he caught newspapers and so on
in his jail cell wrote in the margin
good
wendell phillips for a quarter century
the mighty orator of the abolitionist
movement spoke often and well during the
John Brown epic at Beecher's church on
the Tuesday after the sermon Phillips
declared that the lesson of the hour is
insurrection of that was always Philip
siddhis message but in Brown he found a
man a regular Cromwellian to quote him
dug up from two centuries ready to die
or an idea rather than simply to agitate
it Henry Thoreau the New England
transcendentalist had been transfixed by
captain Brown when he earlier heard him
speak at Concord on October 30th while
Brown was still on trial Thoreau
lectured on him as if he were already a
sainted martyr he described him as a
rough-hewn Yankee who went to school in
the West and the quote him a
transcendentalist above all a man of
ideas and principles to those who say he
threw his life away the role asks which
way do they prey up though their lives
pray no American had ever stood more
heroically for the idea upon which the
country was founded it was his peculiar
doctrine again quoting Thoreau
that a man has a perfect right to
interfere by force with a slaveholder in
order to rescue the slave I agree with
him this sentiment coming from a man who
some years before wrote a celebrated
essay advocating passive resistance
surprised many people but the rose
defense of john brown's force was only
the other face of the doctrine that
proclaimed basically the superiority of
conscience over the state and its laws
by teaching americans how to live
Thoreau said the hero of Harpers Ferry
finally might teach them how to die that
was his best legacy perhaps he saw it
himself said Thoreau I almost fear that
I may yet hear of his deliverance
doubting if a prolong life if any life
can do as much good as his death so that
is meant to suggest to you the the
qualities of the martyrdom and there
there's of course a good deal of
discussion all aspects of this in the
first chapter the sexton second chapter
is called faces and places of the hero
here where I try to catch up the various
places that Brown lived and where he
made an impact in in his life he was
quite quite a much traveled man for his
time and he of course was always
involved where he was later late in his
life fairly late in his life 1850s he
acquired a farm in the Appalachians New
York State not far from present-day Lake
Placid which was called North Elba in a
place called North Elba and there of
course he remained very acting in the
Underground Railroad of which of course
sort of terminated in that area in Lake
Champlain and North elbows not too far
from Lake Champlain oh this
there is a there is there are lots of
well there are lots of legends within
the john brown legend one of them goes
by the name of kissing the negro and
baby some of you may be familiar with
this you've probably seen pictures of it
this had a lasting influence on his
reputation and it inspired a good deal
of poetry brown generally his death and
martyrdom and in other ways inspired a
good deal for of of poetry but the
artist took up this subject that there
is a pain illustration of one of the
most famous history paintings of the
19th century you have found this on the
walls of a lot of people in the United
States particularly north of the Potomac
the last moments of john brown by thomas
huffington it is in the month and the
metropolitan museum of art and you can
see here Brown is coming down the stairs
from his jail cell and there are
soldiers and so on he's going to his
hanging and he sees this black they a
woman with a child and he reaches out
and kisses a child that's the story now
whether it's true or not is another
matter but it plays a very important
part in the legend of John Brown and
particularly I suppose well particularly
among blogs a one of the pull a poet
a contemporary poet wrote of this great
God that kiss it's thrilling has not
perished but on from climb decline
leaping from heart to heart it shall be
cherished till the last impulse of time
now chapter 4 is devoted to Bleeding
Kansas as it was called this was in the
1850s you recall if you recall the
kansas-nebraska act in 1854 through a
new territories Kansas and Nebraska but
particularly Kansas that were the first
to be settled decisively through the
question of whether the whether there
should be slavery there or whether it
should be free soil as it was called
through that to the people and something
called squat popular sovereignty the
doctrine advocated by Steven a Douglas
of Illinois and so there was this
conflict that raged off and on in Kansas
came to a head in 1856 and John Brown
played an important role in that the
importance that this has really for the
legend is that all of the monuments were
raised to John Brown in Kansas and he
was the first hero first Kansas hero
certainly native hero known ad but hero
there his five sons were out there too
and then there was a raging debate that
grew up over what was called the
Pottawatomie massacre and this was an
event that indeed did occur and we have
you began to get in 1870 some eyewitness
testimony of that event that overcame
the tradition that had been accepted by
those who were strong advocates
of brown that he had nothing to do with
well actually he was responsible for it
though he probably did not himself kill
anybody
although that was also part of the
debate whether he did or not
but that debate changed the minds of a
lot of leading Kansans including the
governor Charles Robinson and it sort of
tarnished well it did tarnish it
tarnishes imaged and it took some time
for that to be overcome but it was other
things came up
other people saw new things in John
Brown the blocks for example discovered
John Brown as a hero that they could
admire a white man they could admire he
was considered to be the blackest white
man they ever met and he was a man who
accepted the block as an equal and I was
very unusual in those days now the the
will I'm talking here about how the how
his image was revived how there was
renewed interest in John Brown and this
was among painters as well as writers it
was in the music in music and dance John
Brown enters into these things what was
particularly important perhaps was the
book length poem by Stephen Vincent
Benet John Brown's body contributed
mightily to keeping I think brown or
bringing brown back he the the poem of
course is about the Civil War
it's not a it's not primarily about John
Brown but but hey uses brown as a light
motif throughout the poem and it's very
much like John Brown's body he's
marching on you know and that that thing
though the Civil War was fought in the
shadow
of John Brown and it was fought to the
[ __ ] of armies in the north at least in
the Union to the song John Brown's body
which was remarkable and made a
remarkable contribution to establishing
his legend his fame among painters he
became an object of interest
particularly during the 1930s through
the partly through the Works Progress
Administration arts projects and the
most important and distinguished
representative of this in this area is
John Steuart curry this image of an
angry prophet is carried over to the
very nicely I must say the design is
excellent carried over to the title page
the whole picture
it's called tragic Prelude curry who was
one of the Midwestern painters he became
known as American regionalist painters
curry was a native Kansan and he was
asked to do a series of murals for the
Kansas State House in Topeka and this is
the central mural and then well it was
an age of murals and so on Diego Rivera
and so on if you look at Sohn Dao
Rivera's pictures from this period in
the United States when he when he's
working in the United States where where
he has workers or an audience of some
sort in the picture you can often find
spot the face of John Brown
it's very curious but curry was
undoubtedly the leader of the leading
painter in this regard but courthouses
and post offices across the country of
course we're getting murals and a number
of them dealt with John Brown we have
one of these in the book that is at
Torrington Connecticut where Brown was
born in the post office at Torrington
Connecticut and I can't seem to locate
at the moment but it there it was it's
another example of how Brown Browns
image his reputation his importance was
revived through American artists as well
as writers of three afro-american
artists found a favorite subject in John
Brown a Jacob Lawrence who came out of
the Harlem Renaissance and did a whole
series a whole portfolio on John Brown
and then these were then made into
prints and soul and then also Horace
Pippin of Pennsylvania who did a number
of paintings of Brown including one
which is rather included as an
illustration in this book John Brown
going to his hanging which is a great
picture it really is and it's in the
Pennsylvania Academy of Fine Arts and
then William H Johnson who is
represented here by a very interesting
picture in which he tries to gather up
the elements the themes the people in
John's Brown's life and he cuts out as a
collage
of photographic images from Oswald
Garrison the large great biography of
John Brown which receives a full chapter
of the discussion in this book that was
in a 1910 it was finished and that is a
great bog fee well I think perhaps the
first great historical biography written
in the United States and not not known
as well as it should be but in this
picture you can't very well see it I
don't suppose but you'll see this is the
John Brown figure painted in of course
and here he is with kissing the [ __ ]
baby and other figures in his life are
represented there in painting and that
is called the John Brown legend that's
what the artist called picture so it
rather sums up the whole thing now
despite all this professional historians
are professional historical judgment was
naked Yvonne brown he was looked upon as
a kind of probably a man who was insane
certainly mad a fanatic and that he
didn't accomplish anything and generally
they they just miss him rather
cavalierly
in the last quarter century or so some
of our historians have written
biographies about John Brown the most
important being Steven Oates to purge
this land with blood which is of course
a statement that John Brown made before
he went to his hanging that he kind of
lost confidence in any way to end
slavery except to purchase land blood in
the last chapter John Brown rudra Dibby
'this I'm again focusing on more recent
more recent portrayals
writing Oh as I say music dance
Ted Shawn supposedly did one of the both
Oh choreographed and danced the longest
solo dance ever staged and he did this
in various parts of the world there is a
well any of them he let me finish up by
going to the coda and I will not read
all of that it's too long it's not all
that long really but there's more than I
need to read I think here but let me
read the last paragraph of that the
simple antonyms of the John Brown image
saint and devil prophet and man man
gradually fell away as scholars poets
artists gain new perspectives on the
figure there was a lot of concern the
bound was sort of by by some of these
people that Brown was sort of put in a
box and it was either labeled Saint or
its label a man man or something like
that and that it was difficult to escape
that that conception of the man the
image remains malleable even now still
open to contingency and challenge the
course of his reputation has fluctuated
as I've tried to suggest and while it
seems clear that Brown will never again
knock at the door of the American
pantheon as he did in Kansas for a time
I think he would have been there would
have been a statue of him in Statuary
Hall except that the Pottawatomie
massacre a discussion conflict rose in
18 18 79 that as I say tarnished image
an even the Kansas Legislature could not
bring itself to recommend that he be
among the one of the two Kansans
represented in Statuary Hall of the
Capitol but he still answers while not
in the American pantheon he still
answers some of the most enduring moral
quest quandary and dilemmas of our
national life and keeps popping up just
the other day I heard that Martin
Scorsese so saw scores case or KZ is
going to write a book I mean do a movie
on clouds better the novel by Russell
banks which as I said got me really
interested in this book this is cloud
splitter came out in 1998 and it was
bankses first effort at a historical
novel and it may show that to some
extent but still for me anyway it was
quite a powerful book the protagonist in
the book however is it's interesting to
note is not John Brown it's john brown's
third son Owen Brown who escaped from
Harpers Ferry 105 105 who participated
in the raid and who managed to escape
all the others were killed on or
otherwise killed as was one of John
Brown's son he was killed in the course
of the battle at the at the Armory so
that's about what I wanted to tell you
about the book and I be pleased to
answer any question that anybody has or
try to anyway yes
drove through Uslan Kansas I went to
Topeka Osawatomie are I dissing bill and
when I was meeting older Kansans I was
always asking them the question I never
quite got the answer I was hoping to get
about how John Brown had been treated in
their elementary school in high school
hooks know when they were growing done I
was hoping to see that they had been a
little more ambiguity about impart
martyr as Buddhism you Adam done very
well they seem to have treated him as if
he was just kind of a also not too
attractive character and let it go with
that
yeah well I think basically a lot of the
history of John Brown and Kansas has
been lost I included in here the
itinerary in eastern Kansas of a
professor in the 1920s I think going
around to try to find persons who
remember John Brown or places where John
Bowne had been and so the the place
where the Pottawatomie massacre occurred
for example and no marker no historical
marketed and had been forgotten nobody
seemed to remember it now
about children's literature well this is
something that we plan to get into my
friend Nene ami who is really the silent
collaborator in this book uh did some
work on that and she might have
something to say on that point but there
is quite a lot of children's literature
voted to John Brown but I have whether
he gets into history classrooms these
days how much I have not undertaken to
find that out but that's interesting
would you say yes Eric regarded as a
hero by anybody I mean I could imagine
radical right to life figures saying
that this kind of willingness to killed
for that matter to die for something
that your conscience tells you it might
see Brown as a hero or there might be
other radical voices from other parts of
America it would do well the embalming a
bombing of the girl Federal Building in
in Oklahoma at that time Timothy McVeigh
and so on sometimes some comparisons
were occasionally made - and they're
still made today but I don't know he
still is I think very much a living
legend you might say and I think as I
tried to indicate in Nakota my last
paragraph the coda that it's still
rather elastic rather malleable that
will change I think over time but there
has been partly because Brown was
embraced by American blacks since the
civil rights revolution forward but even
farther back than that we may be the
boys
wrote a biography of John Brown in 1909
which was the 50th anniversary of
Harpers Ferry and the boys always
thought that Brown was really the
beginning of black consciousness in the
United States and then of course
Frederick Douglass close friend and a
lot of other blacks who've taken
inspiration from John Brown and that's
that all that occurred in the late 19th
century late twentieth century I'm sorry
yeah
growing up in hands do you remember
seeing the curry your
oh yeah we we visit raining i me and i
visited the capital of course
particularly to see that girl oh yeah
young man no I do not I do not everyone
I don't think we ever made a choices
down to peak in the capital I grew up in
Manhattan which is only about what sixty
miles I guess well seventy miles maybe
from Topeka but we did get on the rails
yes my uncle I never thought about this
until about 15 years ago growing up in
South Side Virginia gusto as a sort of
mild expletive like D'Arnot he would say
John Brad yeah they never heard that but
I never heard that song as well that's
interesting I I don't I haven't run into
that so I appreciate that comment and
other question am i right accounts of
what he was like to be and talked with
oh yeah he must have been there powerful
personality he was I think oh
unquestionably a very dominant
personality he as soon as he walked into
a room he was the center of attention
oh yes and he he took pride in that and
he of course had a very large family at
20 children and 13 of them survive to
maturity so it's an amazing amazing
human being
really and let me just Richard Henry
Dana author of how many 20 years two
years two years before that
all year which is a two years right he
was a sort of tramping around in upper
New York State in the 1850s and he has
this wonderful account of him hey they
happened to come upon john brown's farm
and anything about dana at that time had
no idea about town
this was in 1846 but they came upon it
he was a fairly young man dana was at
that time and he was a member of the
massachusetts and anti-slavery society
under leaving lloyd garrison and all
that so his sympathies were clearly with
the blacks and emancipation but so here
he comes with his friends to brown
simple home wait a minute that's not
right where am i got this oh there it is
to this humble abode came a tramping
itinerant from Boston the author Richard
Henry Dana junior who left a record of
the visit in his diary that would later
be published after the Civil War
despite the primitive appearance of the
cabin of the cabin horse shadowed by
Forrest its principal document a man
named Brown was well informed on most
subjects had books and boasted the best
cattle around Brown won a lot of prizes
for for cattle another and sheep
livestock generally he was of course
some extent at one time he did a little
shepherding and he wrote a good deal for
an agricultural magazine in Ohio called
the Ohio cultivator to pick up again
from different Dana here
Hiep had books and posted the best Cal
around isn't the meal wasn't a
neighborly style mr. and mrs. Brown
they're large found their children with
the hired men and women including the
Negroes all at the table together it was
a neat substantial and wholesome said
Dana and all the household including the
blocks were called by surname with the
prefix mr. or mrs. how mysterious he
would write of this can encounter is the
touch of fate which gives a man
immortality on earth the adirondack
experiment of course was a pipe dream
the idea was that he was going up there
and fugitive slaves would come settle
and they was learn to be farming well it
didn't work and that perhaps is one
reason well I don't know that's that's
debatable but that might been one reason
and he's turned to Kansas in 1855 56
it's possible there are different
interpretations why he did that but and
that's among historians one of the
points at issue I suppose well thank you
very much yes bill
did you find it your own user John Brown
or
influenced by than saved last year
oh you mean you mean terrorism yeah well
I do refer and discuss briefly an
American heritage article that focused
on terrorism and then there was a there
was a video a film documentary film on
John Brown a couple years ago that was
quite fair and balanced with his
treatment I thought except that it it
tended to use that term terror rather
loosely I thought it's rather elastic
term to be sure and terrorism has come
to mean in our time you know today
something quite different from anything
that John Brown did or contemplated
doing but I suppose in some respects you
could say that Harpers Ferry was an act
of terrorism that Pottawatomie massacre
was five men were killed
partly because self-defense that's what
the abolitionist said of course in
self-defense
they were pro-slavery men and there was
fighting on constantly going on but I I
don't find that very often that is said
Brown is referred to as a terror but
there there are you could make a case I
suppose but I I think it would be
stretching it a bit I don't think that's
a good term by which to understand that
I think it's an unfair term actually
given the connotations that that word
has taken on in our time well thank you
yes well as he made to us
oh yes not Alba North Elba I'm sorry
North Elbe of New York there is now a
state historical site there the American
flag flies over John Brown's gray and so
on as does the New York state flag
and he is buried there and also seven I
think seven or eight of his comrades who
died at Harpers Ferry the last ones were
brought back from the bank of the
Shenandoah River where they had been
forgotten altogether
there was no marker nothing but there
was one man who remembered where they
were buried this was about 1900 and they
were they were excavated I guess you
would say and they were there their
bodies were taken to North Elba for
burial and that happened in and around
1900 plays an important part in Russell
bankses book actually and he matches it
on brown I was still living at the time
this happened which of course was not
the case
but he brings Owen Brown back for this
and it's a rather interesting it
certainly shows his literary license
there that he extends on Browns life by
about 15 years as I recall 1215 years in
order to complete what he wanted to
write thank you all very much
and I what I'm supposed to do is sign
books I guess everybody